Et bien bonjour les amis aujourd'hui énorme surprise attention
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter...
*rires*
Fallait partir ! On avait dit au mot "surprise" ! Et bien bonjour les amis,
aujourd'hui énorme SURPRISE ! J'ai le plaisir d'accueillir Bigflo et Oli dans le studio
Ça va les gars ?
BigFlo et Oli : Yo, ça va et toi ?
Squeezie : Alors aujourd'hui les amis programme..
mettez vous en place.
Allez y mettez vous bien. Tu veux un café ?
BigFlo : ..Non merci.. (rires)
Squeezie : Les amis aujourd'hui je vous invite pourquoi ? J'ai essayé il y a plusieurs mois
de faire une musique avec CodJordan23.
BigFlo : Oui ?
Squeezie : Voici ce que ça a donné (de la merde):
* musique *
Qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire Yann ? (rires)
BigFlo : Pas mal ouais..
Squeezie : T'es un vrai- t'es vraiment un bon ami ! (rires), t'es vraiment un bon ami !
(rires)
Aujourd'hui j'ai voulu refaire cet exercice avec de la fraîcheur avec des jeunes talents
qui viennent de Toulouse (accent toulousain dégueulasse)
BigFlo : avec des PROfessionnels
Squeezie: Qui viennent de sortir un nouvel album
INSTANT PROMO c'est parti vous avez 5 secondes
Bigflo: Yes ! Alors on a sorti notre nouvel album il s'appelle "La vraie vie!
C'est le deuxième il est SUPER
Oli : euh... faut soutenir- alllez CIAO!
Squezzie : STOP ça va c'est bon c'est bon
maintenant vous êtes sous mes ordres ok ?
Bigflo : D'accord, merci
Squeezie: C'est fini l'instant promo
On va faire un p'tit peu comme Stromae faisait à l'époque
Oli : Je ne me comparerais pas mais euh...
Bigflo: Stromae qui a travaillé sur notre album
Oli : C'est un bon ami, c'est un ami
On a dit que l'instant promo était TERMINÉ P*TAIN !
On va faire une sorte de leçons ok ?
En gros
Moi des fois j'ai des mélodies en tête sous la douche,  aux toilettes
Ces mélodies j'aimerai les réaliser, j'ai d'ailleurs acheté chez moi de quoi le faire mais je n'y arrive pas
Voici une photo pour preuve
POUIN POUIN POUIN POUIIIIIIIIIIN
On va aujourd'hui réaliser ensemble
Première étape : un beat.
Bigflo & Oli: Oui
Squeezie : En suivant les mélodies que je vous donnerai.
BigFlo: D'accord
Deuxièmement, on va devoir, écrire chacun un couplet
Oli: Toi aussi tu vas écrire?
Squeezie: Moi aussi, ouais
Oli: Ok le mec se mouille, il se mouille
Squeezie: Je me mouille ben il faut que je...
BigFlo: il mouille le maillot (*bon accent toulousain*) (x2)
Squeezie: On va devoir écrire un couplet chacun
Plus un refrain mais il y aura une contrainte que vous découvrirez en temps réel ok?
parce que sinon vous êtes trop chaud, vous allez réussir à faire un truc nickel ok?
Pour le beat
Bigflo a amené son petit clavier, la caméra qui est juste ici, vous pouvez voir le clavier
de BigFlo, ben ça marche! 1ère étape: c'est parti!
*transition musique*
BigFlo: Déjà on va commencer par les accords donc par la mélodie
euh... tu vois le truc de base quoi.
Squeezie: Ok
Oli: On appelait ça la base mélodique.
BigFlo: voilà la base mélodique, on choisi d'abord le son
Squeezie tu me dis stop quand c'est le bon
Squeezie: Ok
*première mélodie*
Ok... Pas fou, pas folie!
*deuxième mélodie*
Ah on dirait qu'on va faire...
BigFlo: C'est stylé?
Squeezie: C'est stylé mais on dirait qu'on va faire un peu de techno.
Oli: Trop house.
Squeezie: Ouais voilà exactement
J'ai dit "Techno", c'était pas arrivé depuis 2009
*troisième mélodie*
Là j'aime bien (x2) / BigFlo: Là j'aime bien aussi
Là on est sur un truc, on est sur de la fraîcheur. J'peux me permettre de te donner ma mélodie?
BigFlo: Euh oui bien sur.
Squeezie: Alors j'aimerai un truc qui fasse...
J'le sens pas, j'le sens pas déjà
Tu m'as coupé c'est hyper vilain...
BigFlo: Pardon, excuse moi
TIN TIN TIN TIN TIN TIN TIN    TIN TIN TIN TIN TIN TIN TIN
Ou un truc du genre, ok ça te va? / BigFlo: ok c'est bon / Squeezie: Tu me le fais au propre?
Oli: Vous aurez compris que je sers à rien dans le groupe, hein voilà!
*rires*
Oli: Moi j'suis la juste euuuuh...
Squeezie: Mais non t'inquiètes (x3) ça va!
*musique que veut squeezie*
Oli: Wouuuuu! / Squeezie: *clap* Enorme, énorme! / BigFlo: C'est ça non? / Squeezie: Je veux cet homme tout les jours chez moi à
la maison et je deviens Avicii Guetta mon gars! / BigFlo: Yeees!
J'propose qu'on l'enregistre et qu'on le loop
*Chantonne*
La base mélodique elle est bonne, on passe maintenant au beat
*transition musique*
J'vous cache pas que j'ai déjà, moi en fait, des trucs que
j'ai déjà fait à l'avance, en gros là... j'ai le Charley, là...
j'ai la caisse claire et là... j'ai le kick
Énorme!
Kick, caisse clair, Charley, c'est parti!
Oli: Moi j'le fait / BigFlo: 1,2,3 et...
*musique un peu étouffée*
*musique un peu mieux*
Ya ya ya ya ya ya ya
Ok je...
Oh! *discours inaudibles* Squeezie : Il a..il a.. il a
Il a frustré tout le monde!
Maintenant qu'est ce qui nous manque? / Squeezie: Une basse? / Bigflo: Et voilà! Il est bon, bravo! *clapclap*
Squeezie : Oh putain je suis pas directeur du studio pour rien!
Etape 3 : la basse !
*transition musique*
Bigflo: En fait la basse ça suit toujours, enfin normalement
ça suit la tonique, ce qu'on appelle la tonique, c'est à dire la note
dominante dans les accords, do sol fa mi bémol
Squeezie: C'qui est drôle c'est qu'à chaque fois j'devais vous donner le.. la mélodie *rires*
mais j'suis tellement fumé que à part le premier truc après je sais plus quoi faire
Oli: Mais la base c'est ça TIIIIIN TIIIIIN... / Squeezie: Donc j'ai trouvé la base !? / Big Flo: Oui!
TIIIIIIN TIIIIIIN TIIIIIIIIN TIIIIIIIIN
On l'enregistre c'est un tube ! *clapclap* Oli: Allez go !
Oli: J'voudrais une photo de La Boule de Fort Boyard
j'ai l'droit sur le montage ? / Squeezie: bien sûr c'est parti!
Oli: La Boule de Fort Boyard, merci! / Bigflo: Il est décédé... / Squeezie: Oui...
Tu savais pas ? / Oli : Les gars (il est dépité) / Squezzie: Tu savais pas? *nerveusement*
*rires*
*musique complète* (ils s'enjaillent)
BigFlo: On rajoute le Charley
Oli: C'que t'as- c'que t'as pas réussi à jouer / Bigoflo: Et attention, 1 2 3
Tout le monde fait...
Ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
BigFlo : Attends c'est pas fini!
Je trouve c'est trop simple de faire une prod comme ça machin
Oli: Felindra tête de tigre (wtf?)
je vais essayer d'intégrer un bout d'une de tes vidéos dans le... dans le beat
*réfléchi beaucoup*
*balèze le gars*
*cri*
*rires*
Squeezie : Ca ça ? Mais tu vas faire quoi avec ça ?
*cri* (x2)
BigFlo : Ça je le prends / Oli : Tu le prank! Merci à tous!
Ooooooooooh
Squeezie: Gone Wrong, Gone wrong la blague
Bigflo: Ecoute y'a le cri là / Oli : Y'a le cri, est-ce que t'entends le cri Squeez' ?
*musique avec le cri*
Squeezie: Oh! T'as rajouté mon cri?!
Squeezie: Oh c'est génial! / BigFlo: Mais tu vois, j'trouve ça encore trop simple
BigFlo: J'ai pris ton cri car c'était trop simple de le coller juste comme ça, et j'en ai fait un instrument
*cri en instrument*
Oli: Chauuuud! / Bigflo: C'est marrant non? / Squeezie: Mais tu vas me payer des royalties pour avoir fait ça
BigFlo: J'ai fais une petite mélodie ça donne ça:
*mélodie avec le cri*
*rires*
Squeezie: C'est pas mal, c'est marrant!
Les amis après tout ça, est-ce qu'il n'est pas temps d'écouter... le morceau final
avec absolument toutes les pistes activées
J'appuie avec le dictionnaire sur la barre espace / Bigflo: Ooooooooh!
Oli: Oh pourquoi un dictionnaire!? On verra après... / Squeezie : Vous allez voir...
*morceau final*
Ya ya ya ya ya
Attention.. C'est à moi de dire la prochaine étape... ECRIRE LES PAROLES!
*transition musique*
Squeezie : Les amis, voici.. / Bigflo : Mais c'est quoi la contrainte alors ?
Alors voici le petit Robert / Bigflo&Oli : Ooooooh pff..
Tu connais, toi même tu connais... Pourquoi "Oooh " ?
Déjà c'est bien parce que... / Bigflo: Je sens le truc arrivé au hasard dans le dictionnaire
Je... Non je suis plus original que ça (mytho)
Quand vous me dites "stop",  j'ouvre le dictionnaire
et je choisis un mot qu'il y a sur la page
Oli: Ah c'est toi qui choisis le mot de la page? Ok... Squeezie: Bah bien sûr
Alors je sais pas si vous saviez mais ce dictionnaire a été dirigé par Alain Rey
Oli: Un gros big up à Alain Rey / Squeezie: Gros big up à Alain Rey pour le dictionnaire
Bigflo : Allez vous abonner à son Twitter
Squeezie : Ca fait vraiment plaisir! / Oli: C'est qui Alain Rey les gars?
Je- je ne sais pas / Bigflo : Et ça veut dire quoi DIRIGER un dictionnaire ?
*rire de Squeezie* / Oli : Mais oui les mots ils existent déjà, frère
On attend Alain parce qu'on peut pas écrire le dico , Il arrive il fait: "Les gars ! On va faire les "D" aujourd'hui !"
Squeezie : On commence par Bigflo.
Oli : Bigflo vas-y.
Squeezie : Tu me dis "stop".
STOP!
Squeezie: PUNITION / Bigflo: Oh ça va! / Squeezie: Bigflo continu, allez continu...
Bigflo: STOP!
Soit "Gramme", soit "Grammaire"
Bigflo: Grammaire / Oli: Allez "Grammaire", "Grammaire"
STOP!
Squeezie: Pétrissage
Bigflo: Là ça commence!
Squeezie: Action de pétrir
*feuillette*
STOP!
Squeezie: "Riziculture"
*rires*
Oli: Définition quand même pour les... Squeezie: Alors la riziculture...
Oli: ...pour les non initiés à la riziculture / Squeezie : La riziculture c'est euh... la culture du riz. C'est bon pour toi ? Donc on récapitule
Oli: Et pas la culture du rire ! / Squeezie : *rire* / Flo : On va- on va pas en finir
Squeezie : punition, grammaire, pétrissage, riziculture. Je te laisse écrire, c'est a toi Oli
Oli : J'me met la pour la place du mot
Squeezie : Est-ce que t'ai prêt ?
Oli : STOP ! BigFlo : J'ai déja fini mon texte !
Squeezie : quoi ?!
BigFlo : C'est faux.
Squeezie : ahh p*tain mec sa faisait vraiment deux secondes
Squeezie : OK, *inquisitoire* BIM, j'commence directe
Oli : ok, ok.. inquisitoire.. *clap*
Oli : STOP !
Squeezie : OUFFF !
Oli : Ohh non..
Squeezie : Alors la mon pote, t'es tombé sur la fin des "b" donc c'est que les mots chelou que personnes utilisent *rires*
Squeezie : Y a la *byzantinologie* si tu veut *rires*
Oli : Tu vois qui préfère mon frère ce b*tard *rires*
Squeezie : C'est l'étude de l'histoire et de la civilisation byzantine
*bruit de page*
Oli : STOP !
Squeezie : *Monosperme*
Oli : c'est quoi ça ?
Squeezie : C'est, qui ne contient q'une seule graine. C'est un fruit monosperme
Squeezie : C'est GENIAL ! non ? *rires*
Oli : ET du coup, on peut pas rajouter un mot a Flo dur, parce que Flo il a que des mots faciles
Squeezie : Ouais, et Flo en faite j'ai envie de te remettre des mots durs la, toi ta que des trucs simples en faite
*Bruit de page*
BigFlo : STOP
Squeezie : Dysesthésie
Squeezie : Dysesthésie mec c'est trouble de la sensibilité qui exaspéri ou affaiblie
Oli : J'te prend encore deux mots
Squeezie : Ok, encore deux mots.. Alors.. déguster.
Oli : Déguster, ça va..
Squeezie : ça va, on est pas mal.
Squeezie : Et... Mondialisation
Oli : Mondialisation ?
Squeezie : C'est chaud ?
Oli : Non non sava, on dirais les vieux textes de rap un peu conscient tu sait *rires*
Oli : La mondialisation ! *en chantonnant*
Squeezie : La mondialisation arrive *en chantonnant*
Squeezie : C'est bon ? Tout le monde a ses petits mots ?
Oli : NON !
Oli : Pas toi, FLO Y FAUT LES MOTS DE SQUEEZ !
Squeezie : C'est vrai, c'est vrai y faut mes mots
Squeezie : C'est mon tour, vasi
*Bruit de page*
Squeezie : STOP !
Oli : *Rembucher*
Oli : Rembucher, bein faire rentrer la bête dans les bois en le poursuivant. Ah non j'savais pas du tout que c'était sa finalement *rires*
Squeezie : STOP !
Oli : *Pécunière*
Oli : Qui rapporta l'argent, ça ça va
Squeezie : Franchement *pédagogie* c'est pas mal aussi
Oli : tu préfère *pédagogie* ?
Squeezie : Allez pédagogie, j'préfère pédagogie
Oli : ah regarder y choisit c'est mots ! BigFlo : Y triche !
Oli : Allez tient Flo, a toi / Squeezie : Allez
BigFlo : Allez a moi, c'est parti
Squeezie : ouvre le au pif on s'en bats les cou*lles
BigFlo : *Wakamé*
Squeezie : C'est quoi *Wakamé*
BigFlo : Algue marine brune utilisée dans la cuisine asiatique
Squeezie : Ok vasi *wakamé*
BigFlo : Toi qui aime bien le Japon
Squeezie : J'chui chaud, j'chui chaud moi wakamé wakamé je prends wakamé
BigFlo : *Somnambulique* relatif au somnambulisme
Squeezie : OK les gars !
Squeezie : Les amis on se retrouvent dans quelques minutes quand les couplets seront prêt !
YEESSS !!!
Squeezie : Allez a toute a l'heure !
*transition musique*
*Musique d'intro*
BigFlo : ok yeah
OHHHHH !! *clapclap*
Squeezie : C'est propre
Oli : Tous les mots sont caler, très propre, très propre
Squeezie : C'est propre tu as mis tout les mots
BigFlo : "T'as culture est rizible, vas faire de la rizicuture"
Squeezie : OHHH ! PUNCHLINE !
*Bruit d'armes a feu*
Oli : Yo ! BigFlo, Oli, Squeezie,
Oli : Okay, ça fait.. Yo
WOOUUUU !!
Squeezie : Oh OUIIII ! C'est un grand OUI, un mot a dire bien sur ?
Oli : Merci a tous j'ai placé tous les mots
Squeezie : Le micro et la c'est faux
Et sa fait : YO SQUEEZIE x3
Squeezie : J'fais un big up a Mauricette
Squeezie : Pardon c'est ma grand-mère et elle m'aime bien
WOOOWWWW !!!!
Squeezie : Je meurs de stress. Ahhh,...
BigFlo : Il est bon, il est bon, il était bon, on valide !
Oli : Franchement Squeezie, best MC
Squeezie : Pfffrrrr
*rires*